j'ai vu j'ai vu mon petit frère de
saison fait rejeter un casque de scooter
de plein fouet par par mon père
donc tu faire tomber par terre sa
respiration coupée et j'ai reçu aussi
ses couleurs j'ai vécu treize ans
torture
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
benjamin céreq avant la pause vous avez
eu des mots extrêmement durs un animal
qui s'en est pris à l'homme et qui a
vraiment mordu jusqu'au sang il n'ya pas
d'autre choix est-ce que vous avez vous
avez moins génial on a ramassé l'ajout
d'un petite cousine sur la table avec
des cordes vocales à l'air et savoyards
étaient à quelques centimètres de la de
la jugulaire on peut pas prendre de
risques alors c'est terrible évidemment
l'été mais je vous dis une chose de tout
temps été dans les campings notamment
quand il y avait un accident quand il va
étendre avec un animal et avec un chien
l'animal a été abattu instantanément on
peut pas prendre de risque pour un pour
un enfant et comme l'a dit très
justement géraldine j'aurai toujours
j'aurai toujours préféré un enfant est
un être humain enchère jeu désolé alors
guillaume on sait que tous le même
discours non je suis pas du tout
d'accord image hein moi j'en ai marre
qu'on considère les chiens comme des
sous-espèces voir des objets est à la
poubelle et donc qu'on tue d'été un
problème les chiens c'est des êtres
vivants qui sont dotés d'une sensibilité
qui ont le droit de vivre il existe
effectivement d'autres manières de les
mettre hors d'état de nuire que de les
tuer immédiatement et bizarrement fait
passer avec les humains pourquoi alors
ce moment là un humain qui agace un
autre humain faut le tuer immédiatement
moi je
suis le point d'eau tempérée côtier un
moment que pour les autres il
sait bien le pauvre chien le prochain
oui le portail va surtout il a plus rien
c'est un chacun clément en garde qui
nous dit imaginons vous êtes dans un
incendie il ya votre chien et un bébé
vous ne connaissez pas il faut sauver
une personne en vie d'un chien
soirée votre chien
s'est pas fait je dis pas que je préfère
les chiens aux étrennes de dire non
basit à nice 3 manches à mon chien non
mais où les méchants c'est comme les
enfants moi donc vous me posez la
question je
puis j'en ai en fait j'en ai marre qu'on
considérait ce dernier considère les
chiens comme une sous-espèce au son des
êtres vivants mais là son sens ici comme
des choses et spatiales voici un chien
plutôt qu'un bébé de l'asie match c'est
pas l'un ou l'autre c'est la vie et mon
chien le souvenir ménard on peut pas
question dans le jeu même si la question
est un peu caricatural ta réponse est
hallucinante en direct dans une émission
le choisit un chien plutôt qu'un bébé
que je ne connais pas au regard d'un
chien chien loup voilà chez rohmer une
espèce qui n'est pas reconnu comme jour
estime par la société centrale canine
exactement dix ans parle d'un chien
entre guillemets illégal c'est pas quel
chien effectivement ça ils sont illégaux
ils sont dangereux ils ont mordu donc
ils ont prouvé qu'ils étaient dangereux
là on les supprime directement et
supprime donc séduire différent et on
les met dans une poubelle et on est là
non les euthanasies c'est ce que ça
s'appelle comme ça moi je défends
guillaume sur le côté du choix mais sur
le côté vous pouvez pas dire que l'être
humain est supérieur aux chiens je
n'avais pas le droit de décider qui que
vous soyez content eu un chien parce
qu'il est responsable d'une morsure on
n'a pas le droit sinon à ce moment là on
va tuer combien de chiens on va que les
combien d'animaux on n'a pas le droit un
chien et tuer quelqu'un voulait tuer le
chien mais quand un humain tué un autre
humain voulait pas tuer même plus loin
du monument eh ben on a quatre
[Applaudissements]
il a tué délibérément 4 personnes
vous êtes beaucoup plus de gens avec des
humains qui sont des départs dont mes
démerdes or dire violent qui tue
volontairement qu'avec un pauvre chien
dès qu'il a le malheur de mordre et
bien-être des enfants il faut le but
était de l'asie c'était mon idole accès
à ce que tu as tout dit justement il
sait même pas qu'il le fait à 8 ce qui
différencie un animal des trucs à la
raison à la confluence de ces la paix
sont effectivement des confitures
du mal c'est un animal
la reine elizabeth ii vient de mourir à
l'âge de 96 ans depuis ce midi et un
communiqué officiel préoccupant sur son
état de santé tous tout l'angleterre
était inquiète merci bakiev d'être avec
nous
bertrand
je sais que tu es extrêmement triste un
forcément oui j'ai ouï je me sens sale
la salle les trithoises de tous vraiment
sûr lettres-histoire merci j'ai j'ai
passé tout l'été avec elizabeth 2
puisque jeu j'avais une échéance qui
était le 1er septembre et je devais
rendre en manuscrit une biographie est
gelée rendu jeudi dernier et le tout
dernier chapitre le tout dernier que
j'ai écrit c'est en jour il y lit bête
tu seras morte
voilà il ya sept jours jour pour jour et
j'ai du mal à me dire que c'est déjà
aujourd'hui même si je sais même si je
sais que ça fait 96 ans 4 mois et 18
jours précisément que le monde connaît
une isabelle mardi elle reçoit nice 13
la nouvelle première ministre la 15e
première ministre on se rappelle que le
tout premier était winston churchill à
un autre monde en 50 2 et en effet on la
trouve très fatigué on la trouve
affaibli mais ça fait un nom que
j'arrête pas de vous dire l'arrêt
n'allait pas fear and là ça va encore et
on apprend vraiment aussi dans la foulée
qu'elle a été mise sous assistance
respiratoire
ça on l'apprend aujourd'hui
là pour le coup à partir de ce moment là
je pense vraiment être dans les premiers
à former parce que j'ai vraiment
quelqu'un est long très très proches qui
me dit voilà assistance respiratoire ça
commence entre guillemets vraiment à se
corser à sentir mauvais à londres voilà
il savait déjà qu'en réalité les choses
aller on allait vers cette fin est
inéluctable
bloquerait même si c'est pas officialisé
que ce soit à 16h10 puisqu'il ya des
bruits vraiment quelques bruits qui ont
fuité à 16h10 et une seconde l'europe on
en a froid on a plus de rennes un roi le
roi charles iii le drapeau de buckingham
palace qui est en berne alors c'est
assez
incroyable de vivre ça l'atmosphère qui
était complètement figé s'est assombri
dès ce soir la tour eiffel ne s'illumine
rappaz est que dès demain le palais de
l'elysée mais également tous ces
drapeaux en berne alors rappelle que
sans elle elizabeth ii règne sur 150
millions de sujets à travers le globe on
parle de l'angleterre mais il y avait
jose il y à l'irlande du nord et il ya
tous ces pays du commonwealth qui eux
ont été prévenus avant que l'on ne soit
nous avant que le grand public ne soit
informé c'est ça le dernier absolument
oui c'est sa dernière apparition efforts
alertés par la tâche bleue que l'on voit
sur sa marque il semblerait que le
lendemain le mercredi elle est contracté
une avc accident vasculaire cérébral se
serait apparemment ce qui figurait sur
l'homme sur le certificat de décès qui a
été signé donc là officiellement par son
médecin qui est le docteur robertson qui
est le médecin attitré qu'elle a
lorsqu'elle séjourne aux hommes en
écosse tous les membres de la cour vont
prendre en deuil qui lui va durer
pendant trois mois et ça me fait penser
cyril que je ne sais pas si vous vous
souvenez lors d'une des précédentes
émissions je vous avais dit que j'avais
écris pour vous à la reine oui et il y à
deux mois jour pour jour on ne sait plus
depuis puisque c'était des vacances j'ai
une lettre de buckingham palace qui est
arrivé à votre intention la voilà c'est
une lettre comme vous le verrez deux
buggy scénariste c'est vrai que monsieur
cyril hanouna et peut-être remarqué
aulas m'a écrit le document mais vous
avez entre les mains déjà le papier que
vous avez entre les mains il n'existe
plus non puisque à partir de maintenant
vous avez bien le blason déjà à changer
la reine elizabeth 2 n'existe plus
pauvres la cour désormais va avoir un
courrier liseré de noirceur marquer
officiellement qui sont tantôt on va
officiellement là les chambres vont
officiellement reconnaître charles a
comme étant désormais laurent hommes
leur nouveau roi y régnera on le sait
sous le nom de charles iii
on est jamais caché ensuite sur le
demandent donc j'ai plus de la dépouille
de la reine devra opposer à buckingham
palace la dépouille va être affrétés à
bord du train royal eh ben on le sait
que depuis 1952 la locomotive royal n'a
plus n'a plus tracts et de voiture fut
nerf et 70 ans je leur ai fait le choix
avec vos équipes de leur série de rester
ici pour voilà pour pouvoir mieux
commenté ici tout ce qui se passe là bas
parce qu'en même temps la presse va pas
vraiment être autorisés non plus à
pénétrer dans ces lieux là même au sein
même de l'abbaye de westminster seule la
bbc est vraiment autorisé à
retransmettre
dix victimes dix enfants âgés de 4 mois
à 24 ans dont sept mineurs violence
manque total d'hygiène maltraitance
carences éducatives en france c'est en
france que ça s'est passé le 3 septembre
la sphère fait la une des journaux et
les policiers tombent sur des enfants en
bas âge vivent dans des conditions
déplorables des conditions effroyables
ligoté et recouvert des scripts un ver
si brian d'être avec nous ce soir qu'est
ce qui s'est passé en fête raconte mon
histoire basse qui s'est tout simplement
passé c'est que de ma naissance à un
mais six ans avant la jeu avant la
naissance pardon de mon petit frère de
16 ans tout se passait comme à dire
correct après pas totalement on habitait
dans une maison squattée de ma naissance
à un mais six ans un milieu des cafards
des ans c'est tout ce qui se passe dans
une maison squattée ensuite on déménage
dans dans une nouvelle maison plus
grande au moins les les filles sont
séparées des garçons et voilà la venue
du manque du frère de 16 ans et à partir
de ce moment tout déraille tous des
rhein et les violences commencent les
violences physiques la violence verbale
qu'est ce qui s'est passé qu'il y avait
quoi comme 10 ans 1 il y avait des coups
de poing des coups de pied des coups de
bâton j'ai vu j'ai vu mon petit frère de
16 ans fait rejeter un casque de scooter
de plein fouet par par mon père
donc tu faire tomber par terre
sa respiration coupée j'ai reçu aussi
ses couleurs 1
tout ce qui était possible pour nous
faire mal mais surtout surtout ne pas
laisser de côté marques ont pas laissé
de cookies marqué et aujourd'hui ça sert
aujourd'hui parce que grâce à assat la
justice a des doutes la justice mais non
cause toutes nos paroles comme n'y a pas
de coup marquant comme y'a pas de
cicatrice comme n'y a pas de vidéo je
suis désolé aujourd'hui auprès de la
justice et j'ai pas filmer man l'un de
mes petits frais ou l'une de mes petites
soeurs en train de se faire frapper
consistoire des filles attaché bah tout
simplement sais c'est que pour ma mère
qui ne fait rien de ses journées à part
fumer des cigares et et être sur son
téléphone elle ne peut pas surveiller de
petit à petit de 5 et 2 ans elle ne
parlait elle ne peut pas les laisser
libres les petites sont rattachés 23
heures sur 24 ans quand elles sont
attachées comme en mai il ya il ya déjà
leur nez de sécurité de base plus la
corde du peignoir qui sert de
deux chaînes comme un comme un
prisonnier pourquoi chris evans c'est
toi qui a donné l alerte après une
dispute avec ton pc ça en fait c'était
stehlin jean lannes chine la semaine
d'avant après que que mon petit frère
s'est fait taper par trois personnes du
domicile mon père de 2 44 ans mon beau
frère de 20 ans et ma soeur de 19 ans
quant aux casseurs il ya une de tes
soeurs qui a pris fait et cause pour un
tps et le lendemain un déjà toute la
nuit je passe la nuit à pleurer parce
que je mets des jeux mais des coups
devant la file d'un mois qui ne doit pas
vous qui ne doit pas voir ça
le noma eu un réveil je me dis que c'est
stop c'est fini que nous n'aurons plus
aucune chance de faire ce qu'ils ont
fait à mes petits frères et soeurs
j'appelle donc au service des instances
sociales de lens je leur explique tout
ce qu'on a vécu j'arrive plus que ce que
j'ai vu que le pape avait un rendez-vous
et les mamans s'occuper de ses enfants
voilà mais elle s'occupait un parent ne
peut pas s'occuper du bébé du dernier né
elle ne pouvait pas s'occuper de tous
ses enfants en même temps c'est normal
c'est des parents qui aiment leurs
enfants il n'y a pas eu autant de mal
que ce que disent les médias je vais
d'abord revenir sur le témoignage d'un
de ma tante pour mettre les choses au
clair avec un alors deux jours avant son
interview en vain car son témoignage
elle m'invite chez elle au soir alors
que mais lorsque mes parents sont en
garde à vue elle me dit nous fois j'aime
ta beaucoup de courage nous
malheureusement jamais osé rien dire on
a on a vu des choses je ne voulais plus
ramené mes enfants jetés par an parce
qu'il voyait des choses je demande à mes
à mes enfants de fermer les yeux quand
pas y passer devant les petites attaches
et pleines d'excréments deux jours après
je vois je vois ces témoignages j'ai été
choqué hier matin mon réveil je reçois
un message de cette même tente qui
m'envoie un message en gros pour me dire
qu'elle regrette d'avoir fait un faux
témoignage
voilà que ces messages brian général en
témoignant à la télé crois moi bien que
je m'en veux je suis à vos côtés j'ai
rectifié le tir par le remords de la
culpabilité en allant commissariat pour
vous soutenir s'il faut que je témoigne
tribunal je le ferai les médias nous ont
mis pression et disais que ça allait
faire taire les médias
c'était pour nous mettre à couvert dont
un oncle ressemble à son frère et nos
enfants et notre travail c'est sa cause
de ces gens là aujourd'hui que que
l'état va douter
brian ya une vidéo qui a fait énormément
parler cette vidéo du procureur le
procureur de la république a semblé
minimiser tout ça et refuse de parler de
maison de l'horreur regarde les sons
d'horreur ça me paraît un qualificatif
tout à fait exagéré on a affaire à des
manquements certains on a affaire d
manque d'hygiène a des carences
éducatives
on a pas de traces de coups sur les
enfants on n'a pas d'enfant couvert
d'excréments aujourd'hui
le procureur nous parle pas de en gros
ne torturent idée que la maison ils ont
en horreur c'est
s'aggraver 1 je ne pense pas que que ce
monsieur je n'espère pas pour lui qu'il
ait vécu le quart de ce qu'on a vécu je
ne pense pas que ce monsieur aurait le
courage d'accepter tous les coups que
mes petits frères et moi on a reçu je
pense pas qu'aujourd'hui ce monsieur
aurait le courage d'être là aujourd'hui
témoigner contre ses parents toute
l'horreur qu'ils ont fait mélange de
joie des mandats je me suis de devoir
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui amis tous
tous mes frères et moi même à terre il
nous arrive où nous a remis un coup on
avait déjà pris avec ses déclarations il
nous a bien congrès aujourd'hui je veux
qu'ils sachent que caen va pas qu'on va
se battre qu'on va pas lâcher et que on
donnera tout pour que mes frères et
soeurs ressemble amour qu'ils soient
jamais eu et aujourd'hui on veut
d'argent aujourd'hui on veut voir mes
parents souffrir comme vous vous avez
souffert ça sera pas à ce point même si
aujourd'hui demain on les condamne à 15
20 ans j'ai vécu treize ans torture
peut-être pas j'ai peut-être pas été
l'enfant qui a pris le plus de coups le
plus d'adultes mais voir ses frères et
soeurs
victime aussi de tout ça ça a été pour
moi de la tension encore ces dernières
semaines
le procureur est en panne et l'humoriste
n'a pas fait l'unanimité regarder cirque
royal est en fait ils l'ont coupé ils
ont envoyé à tout mon jouet alexandra
bien j'aurais eu sur le plateau de
télématin on vous laisse la parole à moi
jour julia bonjour madame chers
téléspectateurs
a buggé
spectateurs bonjour
moi mais de la wave bouhlel aucun effort
de fait sur la prononciation de son nom
en même temps en at il fallu pour
respecter le code de la route je ne
crois pas mais nous sommes là pour
tenter de le défendre je suis en tout
cas pour tenter de le défendre et je
vais m'y employer et buvait de l'alcool
se droguait ne je n'ai pas mangé du porc
et ne priait jamais comme moi tout comme
moi pareil alors pour le coup c'est
l'extrême droite qui a dû être déçu pour
une fois qu'on avait un parfait petit
modèle d'intégration il a fallu qu'il
déconne souvenez-vous de louis de funès
dans l'homme aux requins
ouais ouais donc ils ont envoyé la pub
alors c'est vrai que c'est chaud
pourrait pour une première télé on
regarde comme vous l'avez vu des avons
été brutalement coupée et donc on va
laisser la parole alexandra pizza ghali
pour votre conclusion absolument je
conclurai à présent cette première
chronique et comment tour et comment le
pourrais-je autrement sur un tour
nettement plus premier degré en
m'adressant aux victimes à leurs
familles à leurs proches aux niçois on
pense à vous n'avez vous causez amont et
en 2016 on le saura tout au long de ce
procès qui méritait d'être entendu ainsi
beaucoup question de france télé les
équipes de télé matin regrette qu'une
chronique à vocation humoristique et
orthez à juste titre de nombreux
téléspectateurs nous présentons nos
excuses exprimons notre solidarité avec
les victimes de l'attentât nice et leurs
proches qu'est ce que vous en pensez à
lyon moi franchement j'ai envie de la
soutenir cet humoriste que fait la
production ils auraient tiré à spirales
à mettre tout seul face à carcassonne
est ainsi née la poigne à paris y'a pas
un plan de coupe sur les chroniqueurs
aller toute seule face caméra elle est
morte de stress pardon mais personne
relie sa chronique il ya un producteur
de cette émission pourquoi ils relisent
pas la chronique y en a
tant donné je ris pas l'europe mais elle
devrait dire vous êtes un peu dur majeur
est la relation a dit un mot aux
animatrices la l'acquitté de la vire
mais non ces jours c'était pour
l'émission et coup pourquoi n'est pas un
mot
matrix and as tu viens saluer checker
par la production donc oui la compagnie
de huy dong rak e elle aurait pu le
faire à la drucker qu'en mer et droguée
dit sur la chaîne si tu nous écoutes
accusé mois bon là dessus à
distance à raison ces bonnes premières
c'est un humour compliqué une pardon c1
c'est un instant difficile vous prenez
des risques enfin voila mais on n'est
pas dans une phrase qui aurait pu
désamorcer un petit peu
[Musique]
notre histoire commence le 29 août
dernier lorsque l'on découvre ces images
choquantes enregistrées par une caméra
de surveillance à cannes on y voit une
femme de 89 en train de se faire
violemment agressé par trois jeunes âgés
de 14 à 15 ans montant du vol seulement
10 euros comme maire de cannes david
lissnard réagi trois jours plus tard
s'il s'agissait de ma mère qui avaient
été ainsi agressées c'est peut-être moi
qui serait aujourd'hui en prison déjà
première question comment elle va à
votre maman
c'est à dire elle va comment aller là
les sorties aujourd'hui - allée avec ma
ma soeur en bas qui s'occupe d'elle ses
petits enfants quand même à qui s'occupe
d'elle parce que moi je suis dans le bar
et elle elle est en bas d'un accord si
beaucoup ma nièce justement tibhirine et
qui va arriver qui s'occupe bien de ses
papiers et tous et qui a eu qui a eu un
rapport avec la police et tout comme ça
s'est passé comment quand vous l'avez
appris pour nous moi je les ai appris
parce que ma soeur m'a téléphoné à ma
maman s'est fait agresser et quand j'ai
vu la photo
impossible il aurait pu prendre le sac à
main ça m'a frappé vous avez vu la
violence du coup qu'il y met le mec
dessus j'en sais mais c'est pas avoir
des couilles des trucs comme ça et
loteries film et film il puise malgré
les conneries qu'ils pensent et voulait
pas voir la haine vous le suggérez de
voir le mec je les tue tous les trois
mois je dis la même chose que je vous le
dis qu'est ce qu'ils attendent pour
bouger eh ben ils ont 14 et 15 mai ils
apprennent à responsabilité de tuer une
personne bien sûr smic en tisane arriver
à faire des actes comme ça pour moi pour
moi il ya pas bonne il n'y a pas d'
excuses de ce qu il paye pas et la boue
j'avais fait dans ma vie mais qu'on
avait moi mais des trucs comme ça jamais
10 j'ai tellement mieux
je suis tellement fâché à l'intérieur
des trucs
pas je sais pas moi je m'appelle en
direct david qui est là qui m'appelle on
dirait qu'il doit nous regarder ça c'est
bon soir un soir david
ça va bien david vous devez nous
regarder nous sommes en direct le
départ de votre départ
c'est évidemment je te jure je suis
[Musique]
mais
mes enfants des joies de l'action
d'homologie de l'auto peut évidemment
se lancer et de la loi du talion
personnel c'est que dans ce que j'écris
je dis cela en prison je ne dis pas que
chacun n'a que ses comptes et on la
laisse à aucun moment je n'ai dit que la
règle doit être un règlement de compte
personnel mais ceci étant voilà j'ai pas
de l'alouette angoissant touche pas ma
mère je réagis comme un doublage voulais
juste vous dire ça va merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]